la estación de tren de cra motors se ha
convertido en el centro para la
evacuación de decenas de miles de
ucranianos de las zonas de lugansk y
done ex aquí en el este de ucrania ante
una inminente operación rusa a gran
escala pero ahora después de que haya
sido atacada esta estación y las vías
del tren ya no estén en funcionamiento
todos estos desplazados han tenido que
buscar nuevas zonas para ser evacuados y
muchos de ellos se han marchado a la
ciudad y ni pro que es ahora mismo el
lugar más seguro
igualmente los heridos de ayer no han
podido ser atendidos en los hospitales
de clamatos porque uno de los
principales fue anteriormente atacado el
alcalde de clamatos ha pedido a los
vecinos que ayuden en la evacuación y
también ha puesto a disposición todos
los transportes públicos principalmente
los autobuses pero otro de los grandes
problemas que está sufriendo la región
es la falta de gasolina y de diesel